.
* Miauen *
Schon als Kind träumten sie davon,
mal Tierärztin zu werden:
Florence, Alix und Éléonore
stiegen mit viel Leidenschaft
ins Berufsleben ein.
Aber schon bald merkten sie,
dass es im Alltag einer Tierärztin
viel Schwieriges
und Unvorhergesehenes gibt ...
* Kreischen *
... aber auch viel Freude.
Hier sind sie:
die neuen Tierärztinnen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Sanfte Klänge *
In Estavayer-le-Lac bringt
eine Frau in einer Einkaufstasche
ein verletztes Kätzchen
in die Praxis.
Guten Tag, ist das das Kätzchen?
- Guten Tag. Ja, hier drin.
Ich habe es
in Handschuhe eingewickelt.
Myriam ist noch ganz durcheinander.
Zuerst dachte ich,
ein Karton liege auf der Strasse.
Aber dann schaute ich nach.
Die Autos wichen aus und dann
sah ich das Kätzchen. Es lebte noch.
Möchten Sie einen Moment
Platz nehmen?- Gerne.
Sie schaute mich an und anfangs
wusste ich nicht, was ich tun soll.
Dann nahm ich sie mit.
Sonst hätte ich es sicher bereut.
Sie sieht schlecht aus.
Daher wickelte ich sie ein.
Aber die Pfote
sieht nicht so schlimm aus.
Nein, aber ich wollte nicht,
dass sie überfahren wird.
Wir nehmen sie mal aus der Tüte
und legen sie auf eine Decke.
Die Empfangsmitarbeiterin
holt die Tierarztassistentin.
Könnt ihr mir kurz helfen?
Wir sollten es rausnehmen
und in eine Decke wickeln.
Es ist klatschnass.
Schau mal, die Pfote!
Die kleine Katze
ist ganz steif vor Kälte
und ihre Vorderpfote ist ausgerenkt.
* Sanfte Klänge *
* Miauen *
Mégane kümmert sich um die Katze,
bis Éléonore kommt.
* Miauen *
Oje, es wurde am Kopf erwischt.
Ich bemerkte, dass sie auf dem Auge,
das sich auf derselben Seite
wie die verletzte Pfote befindet,
nichts sieht.
Schau.
Leider hat sie im Gesicht
auch gar keine Reflexe.
Oh, die Zunge ist kreideweiss.
Es muss ein heftiger Zusammenstoss
gewesen sein,
da sie auch am Kopf ein Problem hat.
Oder sie steht unter Schock.
In dieser Situation müssen wir sie
sofort hospitalisieren.
* Klägliches Miauen *
Éléonore schaut zuerst,
was das Thermometer sagt.
* Miauen *
Sie ist völlig unterkühlt.
Das Thermometer
zeigt nicht mal eine Temperatur an.
D.h., sie lag schon fast im Sterben.
Myriam ist im Wartezimmer.
Sie ist optimistisch und glaubt,
dass sich das Kätzchen erholt.
Ich überlegte mir schon,
es zu adoptieren,
aber das geht nicht,
da ich in einer Wohnung lebe.
Vielleicht könnte meine Tochter sie
adoptieren, wenn sie will.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Es sieht wirklich nicht gut aus.
Da kann man wohl nichts machen.
- Ja.
Schade, dann müsste man sie
sanft einschläfern.
Wir können versuchen,
sie zu stabilisieren,
dann schauen wir.
Sie sind die Fachfrau. Ich überlasse
die Entscheidung Ihnen.
Sie erhielt einen Schlag auf den
Kopf und ist auf dieser Seite blind.
Die Arme.
Mir ist es wichtig,
dass sie nicht mehr leidet -
sei es, indem man sie heilt
oder einschläfert.
Oh, du armes Kätzchen.
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui.
Wie machen wir das nun?
Um den Bruch zu stabilisieren,
bastelt Éléonore aus einem Stückchen
Holz eine Schiene.
Oh-oh-oh. Oh, là, là.
Okay.
Beim Verarzten
findet Éléonore heraus,
dass es sich um
eine heimatlose Katze handeln muss.
Die Katze ist noch sehr jung
und gehört
sehr wahrscheinlich niemandem,
weil sie keinen Chip hat.
Ihr Gesundheits- und
Ernährungszustand deuten darauf hin,
dass sie zu der Zeit,
als sie angefahren wurde,
wahrscheinlich allein unterwegs war.
Wir müssen die SPA anrufen
und anfragen.
Der Freiburger Tierschutzverein
muss für die Kosten aufkommen.
Aber ob er gewillt ist,
ein sterbendes Kätzchen zu retten?
* Miauen *
Mégane hat eine andere Idee.
Mégane, meine Assistentin ...
... schloss das Kätzchen
sofort ins Herz
und würde es sofort
mit nach Hause nehmen.
Der kleine Patient
kommt zuerst für ein paar Stunden
unter eine Wärmelampe.
Die Körpertemperatur
muss unbedingt erhöht werden,
damit er überhaupt
eine Überlebenschance hat.
Man muss Tiere mögen, wenn man
in einer Tierarztpraxis arbeitet.
Daher gibt es immer jemanden,
der sich für eine heimatlose Katze
verantwortlich fühlt
und sich besonders
um ein neues Daheim bemüht.
* Lachen *
Mégane schickt ihrem Freund
sofort ein Foto des Kätzchens
und stellt sich schon vor,
wie sie es nach Hause bringt.
Wir müssen herausfinden,
wie wir die Pfote eingipsen.
Wir haben nichts Passendes
für eine so kleine Katze.
Im Tierspital in Bern
wird ein völlig verängstigter
und verstörter Hund zu Alix gebracht.
Slyton, ein sechsjähriger Husky,
kommt nicht mehr richtig
auf die Beine.
(Alix) Alles okay.
Stress dich nicht.
Draussen vor dem Spitaleingang
sitzt Claudio.
Er ist völlig schockiert.
Er brachte seinen Hund morgens
vor der Arbeit zu seiner Freundin.
Sie rief ihn kurz darauf an.
Sie rief mich an und sagte,
ich müsse sofort kommen.
Dem Hund gehe es schlecht.
Ich fuhr los und ...
Er lag dort und konnte
die Hinterbeine nicht mehr bewegen.
Sie erzählte mir,
er habe sich um sich selbst gedreht
und laut geschrien -
bestimmt eine Minute lang.
Dass der Hund so schrie,
alarmierte Claudio.
Ich dachte sofort ans Schlimmste.
Er reagierte gar nicht,
als ich ihn hinten tätschelte
und seine Hinterpfoten drückte.
Ich dachte: "Im schlimmsten Fall
kann er nicht mehr gehen."
Alix führt sofort
erste Untersuchungen durch.
Diese scheinen Claudios Angst
zu bestätigen.
Die Hinterpfoten
reagieren überhaupt nicht.
Das Problem stammt
von der Wirbelsäule, vom Rückenmark,
wahrscheinlich vom Bereich zwischen
des Vorder- und Hinterkörpers,
weil er die Vorderbeine
ja bestens bewegen kann.
Das Nervensystem ist betroffen.
Es eilt. Alix ruft die Neurologin an.
Ja, er sei gerannt, habe aufgejault
und nun kann er nicht mehr gehen.
Alix ist alarmiert
und Slyton wird zum Notfall.
Und es gab noch
einen anderen wichtigen Vorfall.
Vor einem Monat hatte er
einen epileptischen Anfall.
Dieser dauerte ungefähr 10 Min.
- Okay.
Danach hatte er keinen mehr.
Ob der Anfall auch eine Rolle spielt?
Jedes Detail ist wichtig.
Die Neurologin nimmt
die nötigen Untersuchungen vor.
Wir nehmen ihn ...
- Ja.
Warte, warte, warte.
Ja.
Nun die Füsse ...
- Komm, gehen.
Komm. Ja, gut.
- Fein.
Ja, gut.
Ein Hund kann nie mehr richtig gehen,
wenn er seine Beine nicht mehr spürt.
Um herauszufinden,
ob Slyton noch eine Chance hat,
muss ihn die Neurologin an den
Hinterpfoten richtig stark kneifen.
So ...
Genau.
Oh! Entschuldigung.
Er reagiert. Das ist schon mal
eine gute Nachricht.
* Schmerzenslaut *
Oh! Ui, ui, ui.
Super. Super.
Leider geht es nicht anders.
Wir müssen seine Reaktion sehen.
Er spürt den Schmerz, kann
die Pfoten jedoch nicht bewegen.
Halte ihn so. So.
Nun muss man herausfinden,
wo genau das Problem herkommt.
Genau.
Ja, hier.
Das ist das, was ich denke.
- Ja, genau. Genau hier ist es.
Wir müssen heute
noch ein MRT machen,
um herauszufinden,
ob wir operieren müssen.
Wir sollten nicht zu lange warten.
- Mhm.
Alix muss sofort
das MRI organisieren.
Sie vermutet
einen Bandscheibenvorfall,
aber genau weiss man das erst
nach weiteren Untersuchungen.
Zuerst muss der Hundebesitzer
informiert werden.
Wir können ein MRT machen
und danach eine Diagnose stellen.
Falls wir operieren müssen,
tun wir das gleich.
Falls nicht, würden wir Ihren Hund
gern hierbehalten,
um den Schmerz wegzukriegen.
Es braucht seine Zeit, um
herauszufinden, was wir tun können,
und ob er seine Hinterpfoten
je wieder wird bewegen können.
Es kann sein, dass Ihr Hund
bleibende Schäden haben wird.
Es kann also
ein sehr langer Prozess sein.
Für Claudio
ist das ein harter Schlag.
Vielleicht wird er nie mehr mit
seinem Slyton joggen gehen können.
Können wir ihn sehen?
- Ich bringe ihn später raus.
Wir sollten noch besprechen, was das
Ganze kostet. Es kann teuer werden.
Wenn eine Operation nötig wird,
kann das bis zu 4'000 Fr. kosten.
Ist das machbar für Sie?
Wenn es sein muss, muss es sein.
- Gut.
Danke.
Das ist gar keine Frage. Claudio
tut alles für seinen Slyton.
Gut, ich bringe ihn nun raus.
Er ist wie ein Bruder für mich.
Er gehört zur Familie.
Hier ist er, der Schöne.
Hey, Kleiner.
Ich habe ihn schon,
seit er ganz klein war.
Wenn ich traurig bin,
bringt er mich immer zum Lachen.
Na, du Kleiner.
Er war ganz brav,
obwohl wir ihn plagten.
Ja, er ist wie ein Bruder.
Na, du?
Du bist ein Guter.
(Beruhigend) Ja, ja.
Ein solches Training ist für den
Hund und seinen Besitzer schwierig.
Daher ist es wichtig,
ihn zu beruhigen und zu betonen,
dass sein Hund bei uns
nicht nur eine Nummer,
sondern ein Lebewesen
mit individuellen Bedürfnissen ist.
Wir werden uns gut um ihn kümmern.
Hier ist er gut aufgehoben.
Das beruhigt mich.
Wir geben uns alle Mühe.
Am Wochenende habe ich frei, aber
ich werde sicher nach ihm sehen.
Gell, du Grosser.
Ich werde nach dir sehen.
Normalerweise habe ich
kein grosses Vertrauen in Ärzte,
aber in sie schon.
Sie macht das gut.
Sie kümmert sich um ihn
und er hat sie adoptiert.
Na, du.
- Bleibst du bei ihr?
Oh, hoppla. Jetzt bin ich adoptiert.
- Du bist ein Feiner.
Jetzt ist es so weit:
Zum ersten Mal seit sechs Jahren
muss sich Claudio
von seinem kleinen Bruder trennen.
Ich überlasse ihn Ihnen.
- Wir sind lieb zu ihm.
Wir drehen den Wagen. Es ist besser,
wenn der Kopf vorn ist.
Wollen Sie bis zum Eingang
mitkommen?- Gern.
Wie es ausgeht, ist ungewiss.
Nun heisst es warten
auf die Resultate des MRI.
Du bist tapfer.
- Du bist der Beste.
Nun wird Slyton
in die Radiologie gebracht.
Fürs MRI wurde er betäubt.
So bleibt er ruhig
und bewegt sich nicht.
Es ist Samstag.
Alix hätte eigentlich frei, aber sie
will wissen, wie es Slyton geht.
Die Bilder zeigen, was los ist:
Eine Bandscheibe verschob sich.
Sie renkte sich
zwar von allein wieder ein,
aber dabei
wurde das Rückenmark verletzt.
Operieren muss man nicht,
aber es gibt
auch keine Wunderbehandlung,
die Alix
dem Besitzer vorschlagen könnte.
Hallo?- Guten Tag,
Barbarino vom Tierspital Bern.
Guten Tag.
Ich rufe
wegen der MRT-Resultate an.
Ja, okay.
- Gut.
Unserer Meinung nach
ist kein operativer Eingriff nötig.
Das Einzige, was seinem Tier
helfen kann, ist Zeit.
Das ist etwas frustrierend,
weil man ausser warten
nichts Konkretes tun kann,
aber natürlich war diese Diagnose
für den Besitzer etwas beunruhigend.
D.h., es muss von allein heilen?
Wie wird er denn wieder gesund?
Das Rückenmark muss abschwellen
und sich erholen,
damit die Nervenimpulse des Gehirns
wieder zu den Hinterpfoten gelangen.
Das braucht einfach seine Zeit.
Okay, danke.
- Gern geschehen. Einen schönen Tag.
Es bleibt nichts anderes,
als abzuwarten und zu beobachten,
wie es sich weiterentwickelt.
In Estavayer-le-Lac schaut Éléonore,
wie es dem verletzten Kätzchen geht,
das angefahren wurde.
Seine Körpertemperatur
ist leider immer noch viel zu tief,
aber es hat sich immerhin
etwas aufgerappelt.
Seine Lebensgeister
scheinen zurückgekehrt zu sein.
Es ist noch nichts verloren.
Sie reagiert wieder mehr.
Das gibt einem Hoffnung.
Wir müssen noch abwarten.
Éléonore will ihre Assistentin Mégane
nicht enttäuschen,
die das Kätzchen
gerne mit nach Hause nehmen würde.
Hast du Hunger?
Willst du etwas essen?
Die Temperatur ist noch zu tief.
Wir geben ihm noch eine Chance
bis heute Nachmittag.
Also, los. Willst du etwas essen?
Mégane bereitet das beste Futter vor.
Ein Festessen
für eine so unterernährte Katze.
(Mégane) Ist es lecker?
Du hast sicher Hunger.
Mégane schöpft wieder etwas Hoffnung.
Dem Kätzchen geht es besser.
Die inneren Organe
wurden nicht verletzt.
Aber was ist mit seiner Pfote?
Es geht ihm immerhin etwas besser.
- Ja, gut.
Das Problem ist, dass es sich
mit dieser Pfote nicht bewegen kann.
Hunger hat sie.
Das ist schon mal ein gutes Zeichen.
Wenn sie frisst, wird sie kräftiger.
Dann können wir röntgen,
um herauszufinden,
was mit dem Vorderbein los ist.
Ist es ein Bruch oder etwas anderes?
Ungefähr so?
- Ja.
Kannst du noch das Zweite holen?
- Klar.
Als sich Éléonore
die Röntgenbilder anschaut,
folgt die grosse Ernüchterung.
Alle Nerven, die zur Pfote reichen,
sind durchtrennt.
Die einzige Möglichkeit wäre,
das Bein zu amputieren,
aber Éléonore zögert.
Eine Katze
mit nur einer Pfote kann nicht ...
... nach draussen.
Sie muss für immer drinnen bleiben.
Sie ist allgemein
in einem schlechten Zustand
und es sind keine
messbaren Temperaturen vorhanden.
Einer so jungen Katze
in einem so schlechten Zustand
das Bein zu amputieren,
ist unmöglich.
Ich glaube, die einzige Lösung
in einem solchen Fall ist ...
... sie gehen zu lassen.
Oje.
Hier sieht man, dass sie vor lauter
Hunger Kies frass, das arme Tier.
* Traurige Klänge *
(Traurig) Wir haben es versucht.
* Sie seufzt. *
Also ...
Wir machen es in zwei Schritten.
Mégane wünscht sich, dass die Katze
in ihren Armen eingeschläfert wird.
Es tut mir so leid, das Arme.
Ich hoffte, dass sie es schafft,
denn abgesehen von der Pfote
ist es ziemlich zäh
und es hat auch gefressen.
Man hofft immer bis zum Schluss.
Immerhin bekam die heimatlose Katze
in Méganes Armen
noch ein bisschen Wärme.
Leider kann ich nicht alle retten.
Unfälle gibt es immer,
aber ich bin trotzdem froh,
dass sie zu uns gebracht wurde
und nicht draussen
allein im Regen verendete.
Das hätte Stunden dauern können.
So gesehen
ist es eine Erleichterung ...
... dass sie
sanft einschlafen konnte.
Guten Tag,
ich rufe wegen des Kätzchens an,
das Sie zu uns brachten.
Myriam hat die Katze
ja auf der Strasse aufgelesen.
Leider konnte man nichts mehr tun.
Wir hätten es amputieren können,
aber bei dieser jungen Katze
entschieden wir uns letztlich dafür,
sie gehen zu lassen.
Natürlich hoffte ich,
dass es gut endet.
Das ist der Lauf des Lebens.
Danke, dass Sie sie zu uns brachten.
Myriam hoffte insgeheim, dass
ihre Tochter das Kätzchen aufnimmt.
Ich rief sie sofort an.
Ja, sie hätte sie gleich adoptiert.
Auf Wiederhören.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Das war's. Wenigstens
ist sie nicht allein gestorben.
Wie bitte? Ja, das ist es.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Es ist noch früh und Florence
ist bereits unterwegs nach Estavayer.
Sie muss zu einem Züchter,
der sehr beunruhigt ist,
weil seine Kuh nicht kalbt.
Wenn ein Züchter
so früh am Morgen aufgeregt anruft,
heisst es: raus aus dem Bett,
anziehen und losfahren.
Dann ist es klar,
dass es dringend ist
und die Geburt schwierig wird.
Wird es stressig?
- Ja.
Frédéric macht sich Sorgen um Jupon.
Sie ist überfällig
und kalbt immer noch nicht.
Salut.
Sie klagte, stand dauernd auf
und legte sich wieder hin.
Sie fand nicht
die richtige Position.
Das ist ein eindeutiges Zeichen.
Nur ruhig, Grosse.
Ich besprach es mit Papa. Wir waren
beide der Meinung, dass es tot ist.
Wenn ein Kalb tot ist, muss man es
so rasch wie möglich rausholen,
um die Kuh zu retten.
Es dreht sich ein bisschen.
Das Kalb hat sich gedreht.
Der Gebärmutterhals
ist verdreht und verschlossen.
Jupon kann noch so sehr pressen,
das Kalb bleibt eingeschlossen.
Wir geben ihr nun eine Spritze,
um die Gebärmutter zu entspannen.
Das macht es uns einfacher.
Ich brauche noch ein Palett.
Ein Palett?
- Ein Palett oder einen Heuballen.
Frédéric verliert keine Zeit.
Er kennt Florence
und auch ihre Grösse: 1,62 m.
Wenn ich mit dem Arm drin bin,
kann sie sich
nicht mehr richtig bewegen.
Für mich ist es wichtig,
dass ich höher bin als die Kuh.
So habe ich mehr Kraft
und greife nicht ins Leere.
Anders geht es nicht.
So hoch oben war ich noch nie.
Es ist eine stressige Sache
und ein schwieriges Manöver.
Es ist früh am Morgen,
gegessen habe ich auch nichts
und wach bin ich nur knapp.
Es ist schon ein heikler Eingriff.
Los geht's.
* Sie ächzt. *
Wo ist wohl der Kopf?
Hoppla. Aber das Kalb bewegt sich.
* Sie ächzt. *
Ja. Oh, schon wieder.
Das ist eine Überraschung:
Das Kalb lebt noch.
Aber man muss es rasch rausholen,
denn lange hält es nicht mehr durch.
Florence muss das Kalb
ganz auf die andere Seite drehen.
Ist es eher rechts oder links?
- Links.
Drei Viertel links.
Man muss schon wissen,
auf welche Seite man drehen muss.
Sonst läuft es nicht so,
wie man will,
sondern mehr schlecht als recht.
Florence muss das 60 kg schwere Kalb
umdrehen.
Frédéric muss ihr helfen und von
unten den Bauch nach oben drücken.
Ho, ruhig.
- Hoppla.
Mit seiner Unterstützung
ist es einfacher,
das Kalb
in der Gebärmutter umzudrehen.
Okay?- Ja, so stark wie möglich
hochstemmen. Es kommt hoch.
Mit aller Kraft stemmt Frédéric
mit seinem Rücken die 60 kg hoch.
Florence hält den Kopf des Kalbs
und dreht es.
Aber bei jeder Wehe wird ihr Arm
gegen die Beckenknochen gequetscht.
Hinzu kommt, dass sich Jupon wehrt.
* Ächzen *
Oh, hoppla!
Hey, bleib stehen, bitte.
Eine solche Geburt
benötigt viel Kraft.
Der Vorteil ist,
dass Florence dünne Arme hat.
Es würde nicht helfen,
wenn sie eine Bodybuilderin
mit muskulösen Armen wäre.
Dort drin ist es sehr eng
und man muss das Kalb drehen.
Daher sind dünne Arme
und weniger Kraft besser.
Man benötigt zwar mehr Zeit,
aber die Kuh wird nicht verletzt.
Florence macht Fortschritte,
aber der Kopf des Kalbs ist
noch nicht in der richtigen Position.
Ich benötige eine Schnur
für den Kopf.
Sie wollen am Kopf ziehen?
- Oder etwas Ähnliches.
Florence muss anders vorgehen.
Sie muss den Kopf anbinden,
um ihn besser fassen
und herausziehen zu können.
Ja, komm.
Ja, es bewegt sich.
Dieser Kopf nervt!
Warum kommt er nicht?
Wo ist er denn?
- Frédéric fragt sich, was los ist.
Was macht sie denn?
Kommt sie nicht richtig rein?
Sie wühlt im Bauch der Kuh herum
und wir stehen daneben und warten.
Aber andererseits
müssen wir ihr ja vertrauen.
Ich glaube,
es hat sich schon etwas gelöst.
Lebt es noch?
- Also bis vor Kurzem schon.
Ich kann es Ihnen sagen,
wenn es da ist.
Das Kalb ist nun
in der richtigen Position,
aber alle drei müssen ihm helfen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ...
Also, los!
Oh, es lebt noch!
Los, weiter, Grosse!
- Noch ein wenig.
Es lebt noch, aber nicht mehr lange.
* Muhen *
Kaum draussen,
wird das Kalb übers Gatter gelegt.
So fliesst das Fruchtwasser heraus,
das es geschluckt haben könnte.
Hallo.
Doch, es lebt.
Es hat die Augen bewegt.
Das Kalb hat überlebt.
Das ist schon fast ein Wunder.
Eins, zwei ...
Hoppla.
* Muhen *
Jupon ist ungeduldig.
Noch eine letzte Kontrolle.
Du bist eine Schöne.
Endlich der erste Kontakt.
* Muhen *
* Handy *
Tierarztpraxis. Florence, guten Tag.
Ja.
Guten Tag. Sie haben eine Geburt?
Aus einer Pause wird nichts.
Florence muss gleich weiter - mit
leerem Bauch und zwei müden Armen.
Es ist erst morgens um 8 Uhr
und schon steht
die nächste schwierige Geburt an.
Auf Wiedersehen, einen schönen Tag.
- Ciao.
Wir sind wieder in Bern,
wo Alix seit fünf Tagen
jeden Morgen ...
Guten Morgen.
- ... als Erstes Slyton begrüsst.
* Kussgeräusch *
Und es scheint, als wurde sie
von ihrer neuen Liebe akzeptiert.
Oh.
Was heisst das wohl? Ein Küsschen?
* Kussgeräusch *
Ja.
Es gibt immer Patienten -
ein Hund oder eine Katze -,
die mehr Aufmerksamkeit brauchen
als andere.
Sie brauchen einfach jemanden,
der kurz bei ihnen ist,
ohne etwas von ihnen zu wollen.
Slyton muss sich von seiner
Rückenmarksverletzung erholen.
Sein langer Weg zur Genesung
begann v.a. mit Physiotherapie.
Heute Nachmittag
versuchen wir mal zu gehen.
Was meinst du, Slyton? Mit Papa?
Du scheinst nicht sehr überzeugt.
Na, Grosser?
Er ist wirklich
ein sehr lieber Hund.
Ein sehr lieber Hund, nicht wahr?
Nach fünf Tagen kann Claudio
seinen Hund endlich wieder besuchen.
Für ihn dauerte diese Trennung
gefühlsmässig ewig.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Ich besuche Slyton.
Ich brach fast zusammen.
Ich kann es nicht anders sagen.
Ich war immer mit ihm zusammen.
Seinen leeren Platz zu sehen ...
... und nicht zu hören,
wie er rumläuft ...
... war schon ...
... schwierig.
Ja, enorm.
* Melancholische Klänge *
In welchem Zustand
wird er Slyton wohl antreffen?
Wie wird er reagieren?
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ah! Hier ist er ja,
mein kleiner Slyton. Hey!
Hey, hey, hey.
* Slyton wimmert. *
Ja, ganz ruhig, ganz ruhig.
Hey, hey, hey.
* Slyton wimmert. *
(Beruhigend) Ja. Ja, ja, ja.
Na, Slyton?
* Slyton wimmert. *
* Claudio macht beruhigende Laute. *
Slyton. Na, Slyton?
Sein Wimmern
brach mir fast das Herz.
Es tut so weh, das zu hören.
Das kennt jeder Hundebesitzer.
Es ist hart.
Claudio hält Slytons Wimmern
fast nicht aus.
Er kann es sich nicht erklären und
ist von seinen Gefühlen überwältigt.
* Slyton wimmert,
Claudio macht beruhigende Laute. *
Er hat Schmerzen.
Claudio ist sich sicher,
dass Slyton Rückenschmerzen hat.
Die Physiotherapeutin Florence
trifft ein,
um mit Slyton Übungen zu machen, und
Claudio sagt ihr, was er vermutet.
(Florence) Mal sehen, wie es läuft.
Er freute sich schon, als wir kamen,
aber gleichzeitig ist er traurig.
Ja.
Wichtig ist einfach,
dass er nicht leidet.
Ja, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass er Schmerzen hat.
Er mag es einfach nicht so,
wenn man zu viel von ihm will.
Ja, er hat seinen eigenen Kopf.
- Das dachte ich mir.
Florence versucht nun, Slyton
auf die Hinterbeine zu stellen.
Zuerst bringen wir ihn
in die Sphinx-Stellung.
Ist das nicht gefährlich
wegen der Bandscheibe?- Nein.
Wir müssen die Stellung wechseln.
Das tut ihm gut. Es ist wichtig.
Also, allez hopp!
- Voilà, super.
Wenn man ihn aufsetzt,
will er manchmal -
nun ist das nicht der Fall -
seine Beine strecken.
* Slyton wimmert. *
Das ist nicht normal.
Hey, hey, hey.
- Ja, auf die Seite legen.
Es tut ihm weh.
- Nein, nein.
Er leidet nicht. Es ist ...
- Wie nein?
... einfach diese Lage.
- Hören Sie doch mal!
Nein, er mag das einfach nicht so.
Es ist nicht schlimm.
Es gefiel mir gar nicht,
als wir ihn auf die Seite legten.
Sie sagte, es sei der Stress,
aber ich sah, dass er Schmerzen hat.
Ich kenne meinen Hund.
Sie ist die Fachfrau.
Ich muss ihr glauben.
Für Claudio ist es eine Tortur.
Natürlich versteht Florence das
und versucht, ihn zu beruhigen.
Sie kennt solche Situationen.
Er muss sich einfach ausdrücken.
Er bekommt starke Schmerzmittel.
Daher tut es ihm auch nicht weh.
Aber es gefällt ihm nicht und das
teilt er uns auf seine Art mit.
Okay?
- Wenn Sie das sagen.
Er will sich nicht bewegen.
Aber wir können ihn nicht
auf einer Seite liegen lassen,
sonst kriegt er einen Dekubitus.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Hundehalter leiden mit ihren Tieren.
Das ist stressig, aber damit
müssen wir umgehen können.
Solche Situationen sind für den
Halter und die Pflegenden schwierig.
Aber wir wissen,
dass sie sich Sorgen machen.
Manchmal gehen halt die Gefühle
mit ihnen durch.
Sie versuchen nochmals,
Slyton auf die Beine zu bringen.
Du hältst ihn seitlich
und ich halte ihn hier.
Hilfst du mir kurz? Hoch. Slyton!
Ja, super.
- Hey, ja!
Na, mein Wolf?
* Claudio lacht triumphierend. *
Claudio kann es fast nicht glauben.
Mein Wolf steht wieder.
Na, mein Wolf?
Florence möchte Slyton
zum Gehen animieren.
Super!- Seine Hinterpfoten
kommen nicht nach.
Ja.
- Ja, genau so. Super.
Ja, super!
Nach jedem Schritt
muss die Physiotherapeutin
Slytons Hinterpfoten wieder richten.
Wichtig ist,
dass er auf den Beinen ist.
Ja, komm, komm, komm!
- Bravo.
Ja! Ja!
Es macht mir Freude,
ihn wieder auf den Beinen zu sehen.
Aber man muss ihm halt helfen.
Nun heisst es wieder Abschied nehmen.
Claudio will ihn
aber nicht mit nichts zurücklassen
und gibt ihm ein Souvenir.
Bleib stark!
Hier ist ein T-Shirt von uns.
Huskys leben im Rudel
und müssen spüren,
dass die anderen Rudelmitglieder
da sind.
Psychologisch gesehen hilft ihm das,
um schneller gesund zu werden.
Es funktioniert, das weiss ich.
Daher brachten wir beide
ein T-Shirt mit.
So sind wir
auf gewisse Weise bei ihm.
Claudio weiss, dass der Kampf
noch nicht gewonnen ist.
Es braucht Zeit.
Florence lenkt Slyton ab.
So kann Claudio diskret weggehen -
immer in der Hoffnung,
dass sein Hund Fortschritte macht.
Im Kanton Freiburg ist Éléonore
unterwegs nach Estavayer-le-Lac.
Sie wurde vom Kantonalen Veterinäramt
angefragt,
um eine Schafherde
auf Brucellose zu testen.
Brucellose
ist eine sehr ansteckende Infektion,
eine Seuche,
die es hier nicht mehr gibt.
Damit das so bleibt,
muss man regelmässig
alle Viehbestände kontrollieren.
Daher testen wir
alle Schafherden durch -
heute bei Herrn Dedelley.
* Blöken *
* Lockrufe *
Hier, Panda, hier.
Ich wusste schon mit 17
von diesem Schafsvirus.
Als mein Vater mit der Sense
das Gras schnitt, sagte ich:
"Warum machen wir das
nicht mit zwei Schafen?"
Er meinte: "Du spinnst.
Was willst du mit zwei Schafen?"
Roland hatte bis zu 80 Schafe
und einen Deutschen Schäferhund.
Inzwischen ist der Hund gestorben.
Daher ...
... habe ich seine Rolle übernommen.
Man benötigt Geduld.
Heute Morgen muss er
alle Schafe in den Stall bringen,
weil Éléonore vorbeikommt.
Komm, los, komm!
Mit 76 weiss Roland,
wie man sie überlistet.
Hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp.
Mit etwas Brot lockt man sie an.
Man bewegt es hin und her.
Dann kommen sie schon.
* Pfeifen *
Wenn sie weitum verstreut sind
und man weitergehen will ...
* Pfeifen *
* Blöken *
Hast du gehört?
Panda, hier! Wop-wop-wop!
Wop-wop-wop-wop.
* Blöken *
Wenn sie etwas weiter weg sind:
Wop-wop-wop.
Nicht dorthin, Herrgott!
Minus, nicht dorthin!
Komm hierher, Minus!
* Drollige Klänge *
So, hier rein.
Brr, brr.
Éléonore weiss, dass
verordnete Bluttests mühsam sind.
Aber die Brucellose
muss man immer überwachen,
weil sie massenhaft
zu Abtreibungen führen würde.
Schönen guten Morgen.
- Guten Tag, Herr Dedelley.
Alles gut bei Ihnen?
- Ja.
Komm, Cocotte. Achtung,
auf diese Seite, sonst hauen sie ab.
Ah, ja, ja.
Dort absperren
und sie dann hier durchleiten.
Allez hopp!
* Roland pfeift. *
Ich muss zuerst
das Röllchen nummerieren,
daher können wir
noch nicht anfangen.
Okay.
Also. Ganz ruhig.
Warten!
- So geht das nicht.
Mal sehen,
vielleicht die andere Seite.
Hey, schon gut.
* Blöken *
Das geht schon.
- Es ist gerade etwas unruhig.
Ja, ja. So ist es okay.
Es ist am besten,
wenn die Schafe sitzen.
Dann wehren sie sich nicht
und es ist einfacher für uns.
Nicht sofort loslassen.
- Nein, nein.
Ähm ... 81.
- 81, okay.
* Blöken *
Warten Sie, ich muss noch vorbei.
- Ja, klar.
Bei Schafen und Ziegen
ist es immer ein Chaos,
bis man allen Blut abgenommen hat.
Bei Milchkühen ist es anders.
Diese sind nebeneinander
am Gitter angebunden
und man kann ihnen der Reihe nach
an der Schwanzvene Blut abnehmen.
Bei den Schafen
muss man jedes einzeln packen
und die Vene
im wolligen Hals suchen.
Hier?
Und sie haben keine grosse Lust,
mitzumachen.
Nein! He!
* Blöken *
Einige sind nervöser als andere -
wie Menschen auch.
Danke.
Éléonore hat es geschafft.
Herrn Dedelleys Schafe sind negativ.
Das hatten wir erwartet.
Keines hat Brucellose.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Ein paar Tage später sieht Claudio,
dass sein Hund
Fortschritte gemacht hat.
Und das Team der Tierarztpraxis
sieht es auch optimistisch,
obwohl Slyton seine Geschäfte
noch nicht alleine verrichten kann.
Hallo, mein Kleiner.
Ah!
Claudio ist hin- und hergerissen
zwischen Freude und Sorge.
Ich kann es noch gar nicht glauben.
Na?
Na, Slyton? Wer ist der Beste?
Es ist immer noch Geduld gefragt.
Gehen wir spazieren?
- Ja.
Auf!
- Wir nehmen das Tuch.
Komm, Slyton.
- Sehr gut.
Okay.
Claudio muss lernen, wie er seinen
Hund beim Gehen unterstützen kann.
Mhm, so, komm.
- Ja, super.
Sehr gut.
- Ich versuche es.
Ja.
Achte du auf die Pfoten.
Ich gehe mit ihm.
Hey!
- Ja.
Ja, das ist gut so.
- Komm her.
Komm, Slyton.
- Hey, nicht so schnell.
Allez hopp, Slyton. Komm.
Lass ihn doch gehen.
Allez, allez.
- Man muss es positiv sehen.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
dass beide Hinterpfoten
komplett gelähmt waren.
Nun kann er die linke Pfote
immerhin schon ziemlich gut bewegen.
Das ist ein riesiger Fortschritt.
Das würde nicht jeder Hund schaffen.
Es besteht die Chance,
dass es so weitergeht.
Man muss ihm
einfach etwas Zeit geben.
Aber Geduld
ist nicht unbedingt Claudios Stärke.
Allez.
Lass ihn, lass ihn!
Ich muss ihm helfen, aber man sieht,
dass es ihm besser geht.
Er wird sich gewiss erholen.
Ja. Hey.
Oh, schau, er pinkelt.
* Claudio jubelt. *
An diesem Tag macht Slyton
einen wichtigen Fortschritt:
eine Pipi-Pause.
Sehr gut.
- Super.
Willst du dich wieder hinlegen?
Fein.
Nun hat er von allein gepinkelt.
Wenn Sie mit der Situation
umgehen können,
dürfen Sie ihn morgen
mit nach Hause nehmen.
Wirklich?
Hast du gehört?
Hast du gehört, Kleiner?
* Claudio und seine Freundin
lachen glücklich. *
(Alix) Slyton braucht seinen
Besitzer genauso sehr wie umgekehrt.
Er hat grosse Fortschritte gemacht
und erledigt sein Geschäft allein.
Er fühlte sich bei uns allein.
Sein Besitzer und er
sind eng verbunden.
Es ist gut, dass er nach Hause kann.
Du bist ein Feiner.
Schon am nächsten Morgen
holt der sichtlich erleichterte
Claudio seinen Slyton ab.
* Lachen *
Oh-ho-ho.- Ich glaube,
er merkt, wo es hingeht.
* Lachen *
Für Alix ist es nicht ganz einfach,
sich vom Husky zu trennen.
Ja, du. Es wird dir gut gehen.
Es berührt einen immer ein wenig,
aber das Ziel ist ja, dass ein Tier
bald wieder gesund nach Hause kann.
Darum tut es gut, Tier und Besitzer
wieder zusammen zu sehen.
Das ist das Ziel unserer Arbeit.
* Lachen *
Oh-ho-ho.
Ich bin froh.
Ich kann ihn noch
mit Physiotherapie unterstützen.
Aufstehen.
- Er wird sich gewiss erholen.
Ho-hopp.
Mir ist klar geworden, was er mir
alles gibt und was er mir bedeutet.
Ich hätte ihn verlieren können.
So, Kleiner.
Daher möchte ich
die Zeit mit ihm nutzen.
Tiere leben ja weniger lang als wir.
Ich weiss, dass der Zeitpunkt
kommen wird, aber sechs ist zu früh.
Das geht nicht.
Das ist viel zu früh.
Slyton hat einen langen Weg vor sich.
Claudio wird ihn begleiten
und unterstützen - mit Geduld.
* Sanfte Klänge *
* Claudio lacht. *
* Fröhliche Klänge *
Wer ist der Beste?
Hoppla. Sehr gut.
* Lachen *
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021